عملاقه تقنيه ميته في خطوه يراها البعض
متوقع لم تعد منصات العالميه فيسبوك
وانستجرام مجانيه بشكل كامل بعد اليوم
فالعلامه الزرقاء او رمز التحقق باسمها
التقني اصبحت من الان فصاعدا بمقابل مادي
بدايه استراليا نيوزيلندا والاسبوع المقبل
العلامه التي حملت قيمه مضافه واصبحت بابا
يطرقه المشاهير ليوثقوا حساباتهم تواجه
اليوم تهديدا ان تفقد قيمتها ونجوميتها
خصوصا مع رفض عدد لا باس به ان يدفعوا
مقابلها لكن الخساره قد تكون متبادله بين
ميثه والمشاهير وهذا الربح الذي ترجوه متى
قد ينعكس سلبا على قيمه العلامه الزرقاء
معنويا وربما يكون الاكثر ربحا هم الناس
العاديون فالذي يستطيع الدفع المال سيكون
بحساب جانب صوره العلامه الزرقاء الشهيره
لكن الحديث الاهم هو ما ستحصده ميته من
هذه الاشتراكات الشهريه المزيد
بحسب اخر احصائيات موقع الذي حلل نموذج
اعمال 2022 فان الارباح تقسم لعده ارقام
والايرادات تاتي من طرق مختلفه نحو 113
مليار دولار تقريبا تاتي من الاعلانات
التي تنتشر عبر فيسبوك وانستجرام بشكل
كبير اكثر من اثنين مليار دولار امريكي
تاتي من المبيعات الاجهزه التي تنتجها
كنظارات الرقميه وغيرها من منتجات الواقع
الافتراضي ايضا يربح فيسبوك من المدفوعات
والرسوم المفروضه على نوع معين من
المستخدمين ما يزيد عن 809 مليون دولار
116 مليار دولار امريكي كانت معدل ما
حققتهم شركه ميتا خلال سنه 2022
لكنها وبسبب البيتافيرس فقد انخفضت سمها
كثيرا عن السابق مما يصل الى 26 مليار
دولار امريكي خلال الربع الاخير من العام
الفائت
اذا كانت توثيق بالنسبه لي مفيد يعني
بيعطيني ميزات بيعطيني خيارات افضل من
ناحيه
المقاطع الدعم الفني
حسابي اكثر تفاعل اكثر تاثير ممكن لا طبعا
ضد توثيق يكون بمبالغ لانه الشخصيه ممكن
حسابات العامه ممكن لانه
المعرض للانتهاك لا حسابه فلوس
والله ما يحتاج اني اوثق بفلوس شغل الحساب
حقي وما يحتاج انه اثق بفلوس الان
[موسيقى]
ما يفرق لانه مردود مالي ما عندي انا لو
في عايد مادي ما في مشكله
ما عندي الشهره او متابعين اللي استفيد
منه فعلا حاجه زي كذا الفكره اننا يعني ما
اعتقدش ان انا هعمل الموضوع ده لسبب اللي
بيوثق او يعمل حاجه زي كده بيبقى مهتم
اكتر بالسوشيال ميديا او كده وانا حاليا
الفتره دي مش مركز خالص السوشيال ميديا
يعني يعني مش مش لازم اعمله يعني الفتره
دي لا طبعا لانه حقيقه انا اشوف المعدن
والجوهر في المعنى اللي انت تقدمه مو في
التوثيق
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الى رونالدو المستشار ان
المعلومات والتحول الرقمي اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه
بعد تويتر ها هي متى سواء انستغرام او
فيسبوك تربط علامه الزرقاء باشتراك مدفوع
ما الاسباب التي دفعت مثل لذلك اولا
اول شيء صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير لكل
المشاهدين بطبيعه الحال يعني مثل ما
بالارقام بالتقرير السابق انخفضت اذا بدك
مداخيل شركه ميتايل فيسبوك وانستجرام
وغيرها باكثر من 8% يعني عم نحكي 10 مليار
دولار لعده اسباب اول سبب اللي هو موضوع
الاعلانات يلي من ورا اللي عم تعملوا اذا
بدك ابل بموضوع الخصوصيه ما بقى عم بيقدر
ياخذه كثير معلومات المستخدمين وما عم
بيقدروا يساهم باعلانات فانخفضت مداخلهم
للاعلانات
الشركات
على مصدر دخل ثاني
مربحه لعمالقه تكنولوجيا لا قيمه مضافه
لصاحب الحساب
لا هلا هنا بطبيعه الحال اذا بدك شيء مربح
على شركه ميتى او تويتر من الشركات بس
كمان هن شو عم يجي يقدموا لك خدمات اضافيه
راح يوصل لعدد اكبر من العالم اذا حدا عم
يعمل
حسابك بشكل افضل راح يكون في عندك كونتاك
مع السبورت تبع شركه ميتا او تويتر بشكل
افضل فهو الخدمات كلهم راح يكونوا موجودين
بس للحسابات الموسطه طيب اللي ما فهمته
رئيس ميتا يقول ان هذه الخطوه في الدفع
مقابل العلامه الزرقاء سيساهم في الامان
والمصداقيه على تطبيقات منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي لكن منصات اخرى تويتر شهدت شان
نوفمبر الماضي وقف الدفع بسبب نجاح شخص
اشخاص في انتحال شخصيات كبرى وانتحال صفه
اشخاص مشهورين وقاموا بالاشتراك مقابل
الحصول على العلامه الزرقاء يعني هل هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ما حصل
بطبيعه الحال في مخاوف كرمال هيك
تاخذ حساب باسم اي شركه او اي مؤسسه بلا
ما تكون مقدمه كل الاثباتات والبراهين
لهلا عملو اي حدا يوثق حسابه بلا ما يكون
معه
بياكد صاحب هذا الحساب او هو باكد ملكيته
لهذا الهويه يعني حتى ولو حتى ولو المساله
انه صارت تاكيد لصاحب هذا الحساب على اسمه
ماذا لو ارهابي او متشدد دفع هالمصاري
وصار الحساب موثق وخصوصا الحسابات الموثقه
تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من حيث المعامله في
العالم الافتراضي
هذه النقطه الاساسيه اللي حضرتكم سكنتوها
كمان بالمقدمه لما كنت عم تناقشوا
بالموضوع قبل كان موضوع النهارده
حساب موثوق انا بقدر اوصف فيه
هلا اتغيرت النصر لهذا الموضوع ومثل ما
ذكرنا اي شخص مجرد ما دفع مصاري وباكد انه
هم الكيتو
اكونت بطلت رح تكون مثل قبل كانوا هذا
الحساب صاحب مصداقيه صار بس انه هذا حساب
معه بطاقه هويه وقدر يدفع المصاري فقط لا
غير طيب هل خسرت العلامه الزرقاء قيمتها
بعدها ان تحولت مقابل المال امانه هي ما
قصدت اذا بدك اوجه استعمالها يعني
نحن بنفوت على لينك هذا الموضوع موجود من
قبل كتير في حسابات عاديه في حسابات
بنسميهم بريميوم اكونت يلي هي فيها خدمات
اكثر مشان هذا
الشخص كثير مهم او شيء هذا عم بيدفع
بمبالغ اكثر تياخذ خدمات اكثر نحن ما ننسى
كل المنصات فيسبوك انستقرام لنا سنين
بنستخدمهم بشكل مجاني طب شو المقابل اللي
كنا نحن عم ندفعه كنا عم ندفع الداتا
تبعيتنا هلا ما بقى عم يقدر يستفيدوا كثير
من الداتا تبعولنا مثل قبل اعلانات بدهم
شيء
طيب انت كتير مختص ومهتم بهالمواضيع بتنصح
العالم انه فعلا يروحوا يدفعوا حساباتهم
انا برايي المبلغ اللي عم بحكي فيه 12
دولار بالشهر اكيد وخاصه يعني
هذا الموضوع وما انهم اشخاص اذا بدك
سوشيال ميديا اكسبورت او بيشتغلوا
بالاعلام او بالميديا
مثل حضرتكم او متل او الاشخاص يلي هن
بابلك فجر بمحل معين او عندهم محتوى عم
بيقدموه هيك لا اكيد ساعتها بيقدروا يحمل
حالهم بيقدروا يوصلوا المحتوى لهم بشكل
افضل وكمان بالنهايه انا عم بكون عم بدفع
مقابل الخدمه اللي انا عم بعملها
وبالنهايه اشخاص كثير وصل لملايين الفلورز
ما حيستغنوا عنهم بس كلمتنا دولار بالشهر
طب حتى الان رولان ما فهمت ايش الفرق بين
الحسابات الموثقه والحسابات غير الموثقه
اليوم على التويتر الذي استخدم هذه
الخاصيه حتى الان الكويت من الكويت
شكرا جزيلا لك